[Music]
so the footage on your screen the
picture looking at right there was shot
by one of our producers last week we
were out in California all week in Los
Angeles supposedly one of the richest
cities in the world and in some ways it
is but the video you're watching shows
something else
California is poor meandering trash
filled streets right in the middle of
the city right downtown block after
block homeless encampments along the
sidewalks blanketing downtown LA the
footage you're watching starts at 5th
Street and San Pedro and goes west again
block after block 10th after 10th this
is how the poor spent Easter Sunday in
California they weren't clustered along
a single road either it wasn't just like
Skid Row it was like many Skid Row's we
drove down three completely different
blocks and the encampments just
continued looks like Tegucigalpa or
port-au-prince but it's not it's
America's second largest city the
encampments begin just two blocks away
from Little Tokyo one of LA's major
tourist destinations nearby apartments
rent for 3500 bucks a month you might be
wondering with so many people priced out
of local housing that people are
literally living in our v's miles of our
v's parked along the streets and as
you're watching here intense
why wouldn't oka leaders want to slow or
stop the flow of new arrivals to get
prices under control to opening up new
housing they're doing the opposite la is
a sanctuary city in a sanctuary state
every politician there with any ambition
will denounce our borders an atrocity
and an immigration enforcement is an
abomination the poor in California are
an afterthought one of the reasons why
they're multiplying that's why when
California governor Gavin Newsom decided
to fight poverty last week he flew to
another country to do it El Salvador the
same people who want no limits on people
moving here can't even house the people
who already live here tells you a lot